die erste woche neue groko haben wir
hinter uns da kann man natürlich nicht
nur um merken das geht nicht man muss
auch mal das positive sehen zum beispiel
gibt's demnächst mehr kindergeld vor
allem ab 2021 eine feine geste finde ich
reden wir drüber mit einem der
erfolglosesten deutschen
kinderliedermacher mit friedemann weise
berger ja
25 euro mehr kindergeld viele sagen das
ist gar nicht so viel aber für 25 euro
kriegst du schon amazon prime und
netflix
da brauchst du wirklich keinen
kita-platz mehr kinder sind gern mein
thema ich habe auch jetzt eine kleine
tochter und ich weiß noch gar nicht wie
die heißt er nicht ich habe sie gefragt
aber sie spricht noch sehr undeutlich
die ist auch der grund warum ich noch
ein bisschen so durch den wind wenn sie
merken dass ein bisschen durch min
ich wusste meine kleine tochter eben
noch eine stunde vor der sendung ins
krankenhaus bringen ist nicht schlimm
ist keine angst wir haben nur für heute
abend kein babysitter gefunden
neben spaß wir haben gar kein gesucht
man muss auch loslassen können man muss
gehen auch loslassen können ich bin halt
keiner von diesen helikopter fährt dann
freunde von mir sind ohne die haben
sofort vom jahren kind gekriegt und die
waren von anfang an so wollten die alles
richtig machen jede studie durchgelesen
alles durchgelesen und da gibt's ja
diese schöne studie die kennen sie
bestimmt die besagt wenn man dem kind im
bauch im bauch der mutter wohlgemerkt in
klassische musik zu führt mit kopfhörern
gibt es eine hohe chance dass das kind
hochbegabt wird sowie das publikum hier
und das wollten die unbedingt haben
anders gemacht extra 900 euro kopfhörer
gekauft acht stunden am tag drauf
gehalten alles richtig gemacht
bis auf die haben mozart genommen und
wie sie wissen werden die studie war mit
beethoven mozart war die studie wo die
kühe mehr milch geben
der jetzt jetzt sitzt der kleine spinne
im jahr immer im garten und frisst gras
muss man immer genau aufpassen bei so
bei so ratgeberbüchern so ist ja ein
riesiger markt diese erziehungsratgebern
eines der bekanntesten bücher ist ja
jedes kind kann schlafen lernen kennen
sie wahrscheinlich sehr häufig verkauft
worden
ich habe jetzt auch ein ratgeber lied
geschrieben meist so ähnlich aber nicht
jedes kind kann schlafen lernen sondern
jedes kind kann schreien lernen
[Musik]
sind ganz schnell lernen das ist gar
nicht so hart
du musst nur den drei erwärmen auf 180
nach hinten schreiben lernt
das gilt für klein wie groß rekens
einfach ungefragt bei bauland auf den
schultern schneiden lernen ich sag's dir
ganz konkret geht es auf dem wickeltisch
und er den jakobsweg auf den wickeltisch
jakobsweg dabei
die duh
jedes kind kann schreiben lernen sogar
mit einem lied helene fischer auf und
schnelles auf dem hintern schreien
lernen was ist denn schon dabei
schicksals ausland journalist ein jahr
in die türkei verstehen lernen ja
sogar auf eins verspricht ihm ein
überraschungsei die überraschung gibt
ihm kreist die partie wie die da oben
die breite die partie
jedes kind kann schlafen lernen du
kannst es jetzt erfahren
hängen über das babybett ein foto von
jens spahn
[Applaus]